I actually really enjoyed their
breakdown because there were things that
they were talking about that what you're
just moving around so much it doesn't
look pleasant to the eye on camera as
Christ we take this whole conversation
you think for real
hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I am jak away we have jab eco a with us
today because we're gonna watch from
quarter one of the best YouTube channels
in the world you've seen these guys
before I've watched a lot of their stuff
actually they are addicting I made sure
Jeff II did not see this video because I
wanted to cover with him because he's
all about that Bollywood at the jab you
Kuwait channel it's funny is the very
first image here is not even Bollywood
and he'll wood corridor
this is VFX artists react to Bollywood
bad and great CGI I'd say we just swing
on into things exciting episode we're
doing Bollywood today he's my baby yeah
that's right he had a baby beautiful
what are we gonna do without Nico here
[Music]
that's not Bollywood that's just silly
the stretching of the face and stuff I
mean unless it's Old Baldy was before I
came along
hey guys my name's Sam I know you know
me Sam how do you try to seem like I
know what I'm talking about
well baahubali
again not Bollywood but a lot of these
comments are filled with Wow
I love that
[Music]
oh my goodness Steve look at that that's
how you intro that was the coolest thing
I've seen the transition so sweet
whoa they do that in this movie
[Music]
Oh will happen so many splinters so many
boo-boos this is really well made really
well produced that was like 300 on they
hate when you compare it to 300 - so
they get one in the premises that the
hold on to each other and they curl up
into each other to block the arrows the
train for that scene is about is a bunch
of crazy stuff no one cares about
physics here basically when they're
midair at 500% CG once the speech
clearly around it becomes real that's a
bonus game and then it transitions see
right there that's a great transition
that's really cool this job is a really
good example of CG transitions generally
like impact points are some of the best
moments in a shot to transition from
something that's fake to something
that's real it's a really common trick
to look out for when watching any visual
effects strategy if you see someone
flying and then land on the ground that
transition point is generally the moment
their feet touch or anytime there's like
a sharp movement that was Maria
the shot right here they transition to
an element that doesn't have any motion
blur the whole background has motion
blur but the opposite example where
those are three real plates of people on
wire work but when they pull back to
show the fall they have cge doubles that
are doing the fall so-oh ensures a clear
transition point this is a single smooth
camera move it's slow motion like
there's nowhere to hide that transition
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
there's a lot going on and they sound
like that splinter the catapult getting
splintered into a million pieces oh look
at a guy cheering yeah well there's one
and then plenty this is like a seed you
dude yeah there's a super cg people he's
just standing there and you just goes so
this is again what you're talking about
saying there's another impact transition
from the CG shields so these guys
actually jumping if you look at the
shield like the lighting and rendering
quality of them is really really close
to the live-action version yeah see that
yeah it's extremely close I would bet
that there's still CG cuz look see this
shields Center it freezes while they're
still moving the center middle shield
freezes for like four frames while
everything else you're angling it's not
actually real yet it's still the CG
shield and that's how they're able to
move them so fast because those would be
heavy that is smart like I'm willing to
bet the the main guy who's running in
he's not actually holding the shield
shield that's the trick you just keep
people guessing is it real or not
because sometimes it is and sometimes it
isn't keep the illusion going that's
some good stuff right there you seen
this this is not Bollywood
Oh reow the Indian Terminator yeah he's
a robot whoa he's got magnet hey he's
like Magneto
I actually enjoyed this movie but a bit
it's insane what does he know that we
don't that guy is a super famous
yeah that's Rajnikanth dude he's awesome
I love how they just like filmed this
with real traffic by the way this is
like they're actually in traffic they
don't close the roads off completely
is this where you eat jean-claude
you see that shot clock night over here
what whoa
that was you
what the hell what the hell that
sequence is pretty crazy a lot of the
visual effects is right there to enhance
and highlight the extreme wire work and
rigging work that's done constantly
because every single time someone midair
you see a car floating for a second like
99% of that stuff is being done with
like cranes and rainbows you're really
in there what I love about these things
is the scale like literally it's there's
swinging cars around with cables so a
ton of the VFX work has gone into
painting those wires and those cranes
and rigs out that's an invisible effect
which we're doing an episode on by the
way so subscribe if you guys want to
check out the invisible next episode so
let's break down some of the actual
technical things going on in the scene
this heads turning around backwards is a
motif in this film generally every time
they're doing it what they what they're
doing is they're actually doing a green
screen plate of the actual actor turning
around right there looks like a green
screen plate yeah that's a real face
we're looking at right now you can see
like right over the brow above the eyes
here the specular highlights are right
there and it looks like a real face but
then we cut away and then we cut back to
them and now it's now it looks like a
plastic face it looks it looks CG he
looks CG because you can actually see a
little bit of that feathering along the
edge of like ah like a soft edge yeah
and they got good eyes I mean this yeah
they're used to looking at this stuff
these are both the same actor here this
is on the same guy yeah it's the same
actor actually what it's all about this
inventor who creates a robot with his
likeness so they look kind of different
enough that I wasn't able to tell is the
same person same and they're doing the
facial there's a really classic
technique which is using motion controls
camera rigs it's allowing them to
replicate the same shot twice basically
pull an actor from one footage and put
it in the other while having a moving
camera you have the the background of
both different shots with the person in
different spots match up exactly the
motion control was invented for Star
Wars because they had to do all these
different passes of like the backgrounds
and all the different spaceships no no
the computer so you can like program it
in you can just do the same move over
and over again you see in lots of movies
the one I really liked really limitless
oh but look at that he's hugging himself
double he's a guy in a suit that is not
the actor and then they're simply doing
a head request man that's really
flawless that's pretty good for as goofy
it's like the physics are in a lot of
these action sequences there's a lot of
legit visual effects work that's done
really well in this piece the only clone
effects are one of those things that
people are always going to keep working
on improving they make sense though too
because like cloning myself was like one
of the first effects I I ever did it was
literally my first effect ever exactly
because visual effects artists spend a
lot of time alone in when you don't have
anyone around you sure not to be the
actor and in all roles it's basically
the first thing a visual effects artist
learns
dude this guy's awesome
oh okay hold up what okay that's awesome
it looks it looks legit this evening
never have a struggle and it's been how
long have is this Wow
it's obvious you know reference there
yeah whoa oh my god he became a Cobra
this is crazy if you had to film a scene
where fifty robot dudes turn into a
giant ball and beat everyone up
executing that sequence because the
moment they go into the sphere obviously
this is all computer-generated super
solid job on the lighting and after the
lighting to that CD ball then the heads
up they obviously have a really high
resolution photo scan of his head
there's a million things going on on
here which are pretty cool several
different plates of people getting
pulled by wires and then they combine
them all and then transition to the 3d
elements and then forming into the
sphere so all the head plates their
college it oh my we thought those were
CG all the faces are practical face is
the one thing that when you make fake
people tend to notice all the other
stuff you can make fake and really
realistic scary we have a shiny wire
ball oh how crazy is just which is
exactly how I would do this as well too
it's like if I have to do a whole
sequence of the Johnny ball I need a
giant ball there in a film and then
they're running him through for lighting
reference so red see this this is ball
right now he's holding what does that
ball do so it's literally just reference
for the visual effects artist later to
figure out what sort of lighting the
scene has what a sphere show you do
really well is the direction of the
lights and the intensity of that light
from that direction
it's kind of hard just to create that
stuff from scratch without knowing what
it should look like a lot of the robots
are CG in this but there's an actual
child in this robot costume they crammed
a kid in there it's a movie look you can
see where the head has to be yeah
is the main characters and inventor he
invented all these robots so we are only
scraping these surface here here is some
actual Bollywood films of our eyes at
the end of the video that's this is
Bollywood Singham is Bollywood see they
got it covered because we're comes out
of the car while it's moving this is
well he's got a pretty realization you
met him
Ajay Devgan amateurs yeah this is really
over-the-top actions you did a reaction
to one of his movies there he comes out
of the cooker
that cars flipping yes oh my god I want
to be yeah so they got a place of the
car flipping in the parking lot they
removed the car from the entire shot and
places in a different shot
oh really like in the car they got rid
of the popper every single time on the
car do a uneven like a corkscrew kind of
movement they raped a giant pneumatic
piston that goes inside the car and when
you release it it just stomps the ground
really really really hard allowing the
car to move up in the air
oh my god is theme song as naman okay so
guys this is one action scene on the
bridge that is memorable there we go
is it a bridge jump Oh
[Laughter]
dislike mi3 oh damn it's so interpreting
my three hours yeah I think I think
single had a better head because he's
hitting his head against the top yeah
you seen the trailer of his vine we
watched it when when you got the sequel
to Biff there it is but ultimately what
these guys are doing here they are first
off completely disregarding physics
reality all that stuff they don't just
hate a normal shot and say sure this
that's Bollywood they can to make it as
intense as that's terrific
and while it may seem that they are like
anime inspired we realize when making
the second one and they're actually
bollywood inspired is basically how cool
can you do this mundane tasks like how
cool is your intro how cool can you
light your cigarette
it's Rosen code I love it we thank some
of the special painters who help support
this channel if you didn't know we have
all of our patients how do we get a
shout out some way too much time on my
show notes of course they have if you
want to support us on patreon there's no
description wow that was great so
usually when we cover a quarter through
videos I'm very familiar with a lot of
what they're covering so it's easier to
like talk about there are some stuff now
I might have been on the very successful
javi Kuwait channel a few times in my
life and I've seen many short films and
trailers and such I'm guilty
I've yet to sit through a full Bollywood
or Indian film should I admit that you
took you to admit that you're admitting
it I just read The Four Agreements
to be impeccable with your word people I
will say this watching this video gave
me a whole new height and appreciation
for it all I think it's easy for like
this certain American eye to see some of
these things and be like well that looks
kind of cheesy however I'm the kind of
guy who loves cheese I eat it up you
know I think those Fast and Furious
films Hobbs and Shawn yeah I love that
kind of ridiculousness but the thing is
they seem to combine this level of
ridiculousness backed with true
inventiveness I think that their
choreography and the route like that
well just when they started off with the
would you call the Angry Birds moment
assume they all lock in the shields and
then they land
cranly that is so crazy and kind of
silly pretty silly but also really cool
and inventive at the same time go as
sometimes in American films it just
seems like cheesy we're here it's kind
of this a hybrid of both my question in
their country do they take it as cheesy
or do they just take it as really cool
it depends are you asking Singham and
Singham returns there's a lot of people
who don't like it because they think
it's too over-the-top and too ridiculous
but then there are other people who
worship Him and love that action
sequence in love those action films they
look at some of their stars like the way
we look at our superheroes so like the
way we look at Thor Captain America or
Iron Man or whatever that's how they
view some of their stars which is why
you can have a movie like Singham which
is about a cop be over the top and it be
acceptable within the realm of that film
because it's like you're watching the
superhero same with like Salman Khan who
did it who they didn't show in here for
some reason he's looked at like as a
superhero in a way even though he's not
flying around you'll see epic physics
like that the Angry Birds moment in
baahubali I actually didn't like because
there's a lot of cool stuff in baahubali
and they chose to emphasize that
particular moment because it was I guess
the most ridiculous in the entire film
there was a litany of other things they
could have chosen to look at instead and
that's not Bollywood and the second one
in Theron is not Bollywood it's just
like it's I'm sure the comments are
littered with people saying that Singham
is the only Singham in Singham returns
at the two actual Bollywood films and
Chris they show Chris at the end like
you could have picked on that and that's
actually Bollywood but I enjoyed in
fearin this movie is like very silly but
it's very fun and very interesting
there's a scene in the middle of movie
where he's talking to like a mosquito a
mosquito
he's talking a set of mosquitoes and I
think they help I can't remember cuz
it's been a minute but I think they the
mosquitoes help them out well that
sounds like my kind of movie yeah this
guy seems like he's the Terminator Meets
Agent Smith meets magneto all rolled
into one I'm trying to think of a movie
that's comparable because basically what
you have is a situation where you have
the scientist who's made a robot that
falls in love I can't remember the plot
exactly because it was such an insane
movie but I just remembered that being
part of it that's who I think was in the
car with him was the girl that he's in
love with so when you watch these movies
what do you think of the VFX in general
I tend to be more for lack of a better
word I tend to be more
giving because I know that the budget
doesn't come anywhere near the budget of
Hollywood movies going back is to
spider-man 3 which was years ago that
was a 300 million dollar movie
I think the sequel to in theory my
numbers were probably don't quote me on
this I think was about 40 million
dollars and now and that was a huge
budget for the sequel to in theory which
is just called 2.0 well they still do a
lot of what they talked about CG
doubling or something like that where I
know Blade 2 did that is but I think it
was the first time I ever took notice of
that effect was the blade to fight
scenes they still seem like they throw
down for production design costumes and
even some practical effects and some
real stuntmen doing there you know
something you didn't assign the matrix
when Morpheus drums across the building
yeah when Morpheus jumps out of frame
and then but I thought he jumped out of
frame and then they switched to the
stunt double played by a man named China
it wasn't a stunt ulu CGI
that was a CGI guy I don't know may I
know China says a lot of stuff we met
China gymnastics Center 10 as a friend
of mine he's anyway that's going
off-topic but China I don't know you
seem to know a bit about visual effects
yourself I mean you seem like you
sometimes do work on visual effects well
the thing they were talking about
earlier in here where he said the first
effect he ever did was doubling himself
I did one of that I even did that just
yesterday I was shooting a brand deal
and I had to have a scene where I'm
talking to myself so I did a a 2 shot
where I was literally like looking at
myself so Jay Devgan I want to be just
like him when I am 30 which is next year
you met him is he anything like the
personality that he is portraying his
clothes he's a very nice guy
he's a nice chill dude
seriously he's not tough I wouldn't say
that I'd say his wife is tough
his wife is beautiful Kajol Oh Shiva is
a trailer you saw and you you really
liked it and it was starring him cuz you
I remember your question was who's this
guy you were just so shocked you saw mr.
president sure you saw Jay Devgan stand
on the front of one car and jump to the
back of another he did his own stunts in
that movie it was a great trailer the
movie wasn't as great as the trailer but
it was a great trailer well I gotta
check it out again sometime I'll watch
the movie itself you can just drop in
your reaction right now
now let's drop the whole reaction maybe
this video very lot
I feel like for a lot of what helps save
a lot of the visual effects in these
films that we were looking at was
actually the cinematography the lighting
of it they see they seem to be really
great with their color schemes for most
of it you know what's a little weird
let's take out the fact that they said
Bollywood when they meant Indian cinema
right because Bollywood is the most
recognizable iconic term but they
deliberately didn't go with some of the
newer stuff that actually has better
visual effects as a new Indian film that
just came out called sajo for the most
part really good visual effects and
they'd show any of that here they didn't
show the sequel to in theorem 2.0 which
had better visual effects I mean there
was still some questionable silly things
and yeah it was an updated version of
this which came out all the way back in
2010 even if you look at American visual
effects in 2010 like not all of it looks
amazing
if the corridor true happiness stumble
across our video and you could recommend
stuntmen react video what action film
would you say would be a great stuntman
one this is like a weird the only one I
can interviewing him the only the only
one I can think of right now and I
haven't seen the whole movie is rocky
handsome which is actually based on a
Korean movie I remember seeing the
Korean fight scene with Megan Lai
thinking that the Indian adaptation was
so much nicer in terms of just the way
was shot in the action and whatnot but
we have a recommendation even though I
don't like that they didn't go for some
of the other films that I'm familiar
with even though they weren't
highlighting all the films that I
thought they should have liked I think
they could have spent a little bit less
time on these four films and spent some
time on other films despite that I like
the breakdowns that they were doing
because there were some things in there
that I'm like oh I didn't even realize
the level of detail that they were going
to go into I thought I was just gonna be
kind of a laugh fest of them sort of
mocking the movies but they actually
broke down a number of the effects and
how they went about it things that I
didn't even consider or or wouldn't have
known otherwise I have a suspicion that
they were told to be as respectful as
possible before doing I would think they
would want to yeah I don't know I don't
think they're going out of the way to
make fun of this stuff I think that they
recognize what I recognise which is
their budget is smaller well it's like
usually when they say bad and great CGI
and then they cover bad CGI oh man do
they tear that a new one and here I'm
like oh there were nice which one was
the bad want to give this like what was
the bad I only watched fight scenes from
Singham and the
that is so intense when he did the thing
with a hat at the beginning of the
glasses yeah that reminded me of Singham
just the intensity of like the shots and
how it's edited and whatnot like it's
just a bit much it's like when you calm
down movie well you could tell he loves
like he's the only sounds like well
versed in these actual films and the
story and stuff yeah and that was pretty
cool I was impressed yeah I was
impressed cuz he actually knew what he
was talking about he had context for
everything
yeah beyond just the effects apartment
like he knew the whole story I was like
oh this guy's actually really watching
these movies that's awesome well he
watched the one they talked about and
that's the smartest thing to do so I'm
glad I could conduct this interview
about corridor crew selection would you
about all these things alright guys well
thanks for being here javi good luck on
your adventures on YouTube I know it's
been rough lately but best of luck to
you hopefully you can get to two million
a lot fascinating it gets a 1.7 or
wherever you're at right now at one
point two actually one point two guys
you can subscriber the real rejects
where we have six hundred eighty-one
thousand followers you're climbing fast
you are stuck in like the 500s for a
while now it's like jumping up you're
almost at seven hundred thousand is it a
speeding up it seems like it's speeding
up oh you're so humble aren't you giving
your kind observations to the lesser
subscribe channel I'm being genuine I
thought I thought I was actually gonna
yes well I am like ready being the
compliment I was like Greg's gonna
passed me up pretty soon look at that
he's at 700 he's gonna be at 800 by the
time I get to 700,000 you will be out
with 2.5 I know how YouTube works guys
I've decided I'm only covering Indian
trailers from now on won't review any of
the actual movies watch all the trailers
you can subscribe to corner true if you
haven't done so already they're
fantastic
click our notification Baljit Jabby is
the american covered channel covers
white people AMERICA AMERICA AMERICA and
you want to see the Indian stuff from me
then go to Jellicoe that's the way to do
it this is the longest outro in YouTube
history
catch you guys soon take care now